everything I said to her according to
the way her mindset works told her that
I had to be white but it also said
something else if you're black you can't
achieve these things based on the way
she thinks which is insulting so there's
an incredible I think one of the most
incredible moments in media in the last
year happened on your show this is what
about six seven months ago or something
like that yeah about seven yeah yeah you
had a Reva Martin on Arriva Warren's a
CNN contributor I'm friendly with her
she was on my show a couple years ago on
the Rubin report and she's a she's a
progressive she went on your show and
well why don't we just play the audio
I've chosen across different parts of
the media world done the work so that
I'm qualified to be in each one I never
considered my color the issue I
considered my qualifications the issue
well David you know that that's a whole
nother long conversation about white
privilege the things that you have the
privilege of doing that as people of
color don't have the privilege of how do
I have a great village of white
privilege David by virtue of being a
white male you have white privilege
whole long conversation I don't have
time Arriva I hate to break it to you
but you should have been better prepped
I'm black okay then I you went to white
privilege this is the fall suit in this
you went immediately with an assumption
your people obviously or you didn't look
you're talking to a black man who
started out in rock radio in Boston who
crossed the paths into hip-hop
rebuilding one of the greatest black
stations in America and went on to work
for Fox News where I'm told apparently
blacks aren't supposed to work but yet
you come with this assumption and you go
to white privilege actually insulting
because my people gave me wrong
information they they told me the whole
white privilege thing is Indian I
apologize correct the record I want to
apologize I look given wrong information
about you and I apologized on my collar
you were
into something that I was part of and
just to add to it my family background
is white black Indian Arawak Irish
Scottish I mean it's so diverse I'm like
the UN when it comes to this and this is
part of the problem with driving a
narrative around a construct like white
privilege privilege is one thing were
applied wealth economy various social
factors but not necessarily determined
by color of skin to me that is
everything I have spent the last few
years of my life talking about in a
perfect wrapped package it was a gift on
a slow Tuesday it really was so let me
give the quick version you know of the
backstory of this one they pitched my
producers to come on my show and when
you get a pitch you look up your guest
you go ok what have they written what
stories one of they appeared Google come
on whatever search engine you get some
information and somewhere along the way
you'd find out that oh that's the david
webb happens to be a black guy that's
not what happened here they pitched me
she came on we had a I don't know we'll
say this we had a good conversation
about William Bars nomination and
everything in the differences of
opinions on jury you know jurisprudence
and other things and then it went to
this idea where we talked about success
and all of these issues that led to her
commentary and I said to her I said look
I started out and my color was in the
factory just heard that started out in
rock radio went through all these things
and I realized after when I went back I
listened to everything I said to her
according to the way her mindset works
told her that I had to be white but it
also said something else if you're black
you can't achieve these things based on
the way she thinks which is insulting
it's sad it's a song it's a soft bigotry
of low expectation based on the color of
your skin and then everybody's heard it
she threw her team under the bus they
didn't hold the line though that your
team wasn't it didn't informer didn't
ask for
that is that what there's well maybe in
the progressive world they go well this
person's gay and this person's right you
know that actually would be a cohesive
way to go on a show but but can you
imagine what happened she's there doing
an interview did somebody go and slide a
piece of paper over that said he's white
yeah and now you've got a white guy she
heard the things that fed what she
expected of a white person but never
thought anyone can achieve this and
that's the difference between me you and
her so I so I don't want to in any way
sue she's not here to defend yourself so
I don't want to make this too much about
her but but that mindset do you think
that after you've said well you know I'm
black and the rest of it do you think
that that might have dinged her way of
thinking a little bit I think it got
through to people on line cuz that clip
went viral clearly your room couldn't
see each other it was such a perfect
example of what we're always talking
about well did it change her mind I
don't know and look you and I think
agree on the fairness of being there to
defend yourself but what I did offer her
was a conversation and in the second
clip that doesn't get as much attention
and I've played it on radio we play it
on television I asked her to come back
and give I said I'll offer you an hour
come back we'll talk about white
privilege and she accepted so my team
sent an email as a follow up request in
her appearance and when I was asked on
television do you accept her apology
because she gave that half-hearted
apology it really it wasn't really an
apology was it was a deflection which is
different than an apology obviously when
when she did that I gave her the chance
for a conversation when I was asked do
you accept her apology I said I really
don't but what I'm offering her is a
conversation and I have offered her the
chance to come back and she never came
back so the story's not just a clip of
what she said and why she said it but
the fact is that she avoided the
conversation that was offered based on
what she asked for
yeah and what she agreed to and that to
me is a level of and I have to say
dishonesty
because if someone does that to me you
know what I'm gonna be mad in
or maybe a host enough or a guest enough
whatever term you want to use to go in
and say I'm gonna come and present my
point and defend it if I believe in it
yeah well it just so it shows what I
would say is just the thinness of the
argument because she could make an
argument with her preconceived notions
once they were blown apart and say all
right listen let's talk it out for an
hour
um disappears and we often see that you
get the accusation that you're a sellout
or this one's a racist and then the
second you push back their 2d platform
you or whatever else
by the way funny thing about this story
she's a CNN legal analyst first time she
like I still laugh at this one I mean
I'm doing my show my producer I think
was Edwin jumped in my ear and she look
at the TV her first return that we know
of to CNN was to comment on jussie
Smollett there's carbon very mysterious
ways but you know I want I want people
to take something from it not just the
audio clip which you know they've heard
and and the stories that went all over
the story here is that offer someone a
conversation challenge them to come in
but use it to tell others that this is
why you shouldn't assume believe or at
least be willing to engage and that was
really what I took out of it and I
deliberately kept the story going from
my person my perspective for others not
for her because it was no longer about
her as a guy that's worked through the
radio industry which is a tough freaking
industry that a lot of people want to
get into it's a great don't do it don't
do it do it and survive it's been pretty
great you get to do what you love for a
living I mean were you see I mean the
the precept the the premise that she had
there that you would be fighting racism
the entire time going up through your
career you see it the entire time when
you walk into Sirius XM are they
throwing stuff at you everybody has
different experiences and my belief
system is part of our experiences are
how we interact with the world couple
bullet points
than when I started in radio it started
in rock radio because I love the music I
grew up knowing a lot of the artists so
it was a natural fit people didn't see
me because I could talk about something
they cared about so I could sit out with
a long hair earring tattooed guy at a
Poisson concert in 1987 with Lita Ford
and Whitesnake you know and I or Joe
Cocker and Stevie Ray Vaughan and we
could talk about things and amazingly
nobody kind of went to color because
once you remove the veil by how you act
people may have a moment but they tend
to come over to your side and when I
went to entertainment talk and when I
did a show with Willie D from the ghetto
boys all right conservative David Webb
Willie D ghetto boys gangster rap out of
the fifth Ward in Houston and we don't
agree on politics but we agreed on
something which was we were trying to
save people in the black community and
Willie I gotta tell you it was one hell
of a good guy on that and that's what we
did we focused on what we could do
together
so I didn't see the the are there
racists in the world did somebody have a
bias against me you know I don't care
because I'm not gonna let it stop me if
I can't go through you I'm gonna go
around you and that's my approach to it
that's how my parents raised me they
said find the path work your way through
it and just do what you can to the best
of your ability and if you have to
readjust hey that's life if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell